today's topic uh trump has been banned
from twitter
it's been a big topic of conversation a
few people have asked me about it
twitter facebook parlor yes
ironically tech talk because he was
trying to ban tick tock tick tock ban
him
it's just wild right this is great
um and everyone asks me my thoughts i
saw a lot of people were kind of
celebrating this and
i'm against it not because i i care to
hear what trump has to say for the most
part i just don't think
it's such a good precedent when one
platforms that don't seem to
very coherently apply their rules start
banning people arbitrarily
and two when you're talking about still
the sitting present
you know whether you like it or not once
you are banning leaders
from the mediums in which they most
effectively communicate with the masses
you have a huge problem imagine if they
just arbitrarily start banning other
presidents with whom their policies they
don't agree
whether it's you know some country in
africa or some country this
it becomes a tool for regime changes it
comes up for control which is why
personally i believe it was zimbabwe or
uganda i can't remember which country
but they just outright banned
twitter and that's why you're seeing
actually a lot of european leaders
against this ban because it sets a
terrible precedent that they could just
arbitrarily choose
i don't like that and then also what
what is up with these platforms all
coordinating at the same time
like he says something on one platform
but you ban them from all platforms
how's that happening are they all
colluding together whole idea that these
are just like
private companies i just don't agree
with because of the fact that
most of our speech is now happening
through these social media platforms the
way that we communicate with each other
the way that
elected officials communicate with us we
can't just look at them as
separate entities that don't have a huge
impact
in public in public discourse they are
the public discourse platforms you know
what i'm saying when you ban them you're
essentially neutering our access to
democratic democrat
democratically elected officials
disseminating information to us
and then when you consider the fact that
you know you ban trump but then you have
like literally tax organizations
who have their twitter accounts and all
this stuff still set up the president of
[ __ ] is saudi arabia the crown prince
who's ordering hit jobs on people you
know you have all this stuff that's
still allowed on so many of these
platforms
and you're just like how does this make
sense and we deal with it on youtube
it's a popular thing well it's really
just what is popular
we don't hear about this person doing
that but we hear about trump
it's a real thing so they're going to do
the popular thing it's like whenever i
travel and i go to the states
when you go to the travel when you
travel and you go to the state i always
feel nervous because
the person at the border can actually
refuse you the access to the country
foreign based on nothing
man yeah not today it happened to my
friends they were not going to work in
the states they didn't have a past
they didn't have any record and they
were denied why
not today okay and and it's just
there's like because it makes me think
of that there's not a rule that like
there's not a rule and it doesn't make
it right i understand what you're saying
like i actually agree with what you're
saying
but it's like they function in the same
way that they're doing and i understand
the precedent with that
like you're right i i agree i agree
it just makes me think of that i don't
know it's not a justification it's just
it makes me think of how they're doing
that yeah without gray area and
without being very precise on this [ __ ]
you know what i mean and it's really
just a popular thing
it's the thing they're not cool if
they're colluded or not you know they're
colluding you can't ban everything at
the same time and then think there's not
some collusion aspect to it
fair right fair and if these people have
monopolies on how we engage our
inability to talk to each other but
they're banning some forms of speeches
we have a problem
that's too much control given to people
who we did not elect
fair right that's why we have anti-trust
like anti-monopoly laws in some
situations we try to fight those right
we understand that one thing cornering
the entire market is bad
it's bad for the people absolutely this
is no different right so
and people are like yeah trump said this
i'm not disagreeing that there's things
that he should be brought up on
my whole point is one the rules are not
clear clear which then makes it so that
this treatment always is gonna seem
unfair two if you justify this and
you're okay with this kind of arbitrary
decision which we can't really justify
150 percent
what happens when it's an elected
official that you like later on
right you've already set the precedent
but the fourth is the cel is the same
ammo
right it's the same was just now it's
just the same ammo
in the other side of the spectrum
because they really acted the same way
but that person's going to be bad
you have to understand that and then
again i'm pressing the fact that
it ain't got nothing to do with what
we're saying right now has nothing to do
with what he says
and what abba is saying right now has
nothing we're not agreeing with what he
said
we're not saying that he said something
that we're true or whatever but it does
set
a pres a precedent for other presidents
to
you know what i mean yeah to be bad
that's what it is and that's why so many
affected
elected officials even all across europe
from the super liberal client
or the right-wing kind are really
against this they don't like the idea
of their voices being neutered by
companies that don't
like imagine if an american company
decided which african countries get to
communicate to their people
ford ford did you imagine ford
has that power it's crazy it kind of
worries me when i see people celebrating
his band
i understand he's despicable to you guys
and you don't like him we can agree
but you also have to understand the ends
don't always justify the means
and this is one of those situations
where i'm like oh and we deal with this
on youtube
yeah right like i had one time i had a
video i posted up online it literally
had the same thumbnail
and the same video content as a bigger
channel
mine got removed for breaking the rules
theirs is monetized and they're making
money off it i'm like
so i i hit up youtube and you're like we
can't explain why
and i'm like this causes problems same
thing with facebook
you really want to know what i think
about it yeah yeah i
did not care at first i didn't care i
don't really care
as much right now but i'm looking at it
as
they have the right
the regarding with they have the right
to ban who they want
if you cross the rules one problem i
have i really rolled my eyes because
the rules are so much
gray area sometimes and that's any
platform that you deal with it's not so
much just a platform in the gap man
not necessarily going to talk about him
but i got to talk about the broader
aspect first
if you deal with a platform like that
and you agree to the terms and
conditions the terms and conditions and
the agreement whatever
is very broad it's very gray area at the
end of the day
they can very much do what they want
okay
it's at their discretion second thing is
there's a lot of people that commented
on the fact that it infringes
um it infringes
uh your liberty uh to express yourself
if you lie and lidar can't lie it can be
actually verified and you have some kind
of power
if you got some kind of power some kind
of influence of course there is some
responsibility that goes with that
if you decide a lie and people buy it
and you
you're able to to to control or
direct people like that in a way that
can can hurt people
or can actually go against um
the amendments you know because he did a
coup basically whatever
if you do that yeah of course people are
gonna take you out and try to not
let you talk yeah
liberty of expression you you could do
you could say things until it hurts
people you know what i mean until
you're spreading lies until you're
spreading misinformation so they just
really try to
control that so i understand that other
side
i understand one side another instant
the other when you're saying that it
freezes it's infringement that infringes
that
but when you
give yourself to a platform that
platform at the end of the day
the one that has control is the platform
when we put that content
on the platform yes it's our channel but
is it it's not really our channel
at the end of the day it's the
platform's channel oh look i bought a
new house
it's the bank's house and then when
you're finishing off paying
your house and if you don't pay your
taxes if
the cd's gonna do something about that
house
so it's not really your property if it's
on a platform or on you know i mean to
me that's what it is
so at the end of the day they could do
that whether it's love for an awful
you subject yourself to that
unfortunately maybe i'm a bit too much
because i saw this coming or something
like that but
that's pretty much it it's when you
think you own something you have a
sense of ownership because you could
change the colors you could post
pictures you could do this
you could talk and it's your name on it
it's not really yours
it's not it's still the platform you
have to remember that you are
on the platform oh look we're on
vacation everything is nice i feel on
top of the world
you're in dubai they own you if you [ __ ]
up
and you don't abide by their rules
you're going to have to answer someone
if you bring
drugs to sin to something else about the
second child i want to be bad for every
country but if you if you infringe some
laws of some country
they own you it's a bit that that's a
platform to me but whatever
i want people to think these things
through and understand what they mean
because what you're accepting today will
i promise you it'll be used against you
in the future
depending on where the pendulum swings
and i really do feel like all of these
big
social media platforms i do think there
should be some government involvement in
them
because i do not like the way speech is
being regulated i
i wouldn't be surprised that it would
that that would happen
yeah absolutely yeah but
you know maybe that's my problem the
fact that i i've accepted that
yeah that's my problem yeah that's my
problem and i know like
it it it because the way i deal with
stuff i'm like
i feel powerless but i've been feeling
powerless a long ass time ago so maybe
like
it took its toll on me so whenever
people like whenever this thing happened
to trump i was like
man what you're gonna do yeah it's that
we do i saw it coming because we deal
with that because
all the people that are on this platform
are dealing with that
yeah with that gray gray area that pool
of
uncertainty and unclarity
you know we are always whenever we do
this content and that's why
you know sometimes the the youtubers and
the people on youtube and
that influences all that we
get annoying we try not to do that but
we get annoying with subscribe subscribe
subscribe subscribe subscribe
that's the only thing that we got we are
so much in murky waters
and we always have a threat especially
when we do commentary
we're always we're living on the edge
we're always on the edge of something
happening to our channel
it's always agree area every time you
upload i'm like
yeah we get dinged for random stuff
trying trying to see what we get we
could
get things for and sometimes you put our
stuff and i'm like
yeah it makes no sense guess what guess
what gets
remember how many times you told me how
is this monetized
guess what got monetized and i'm like
rob i'm done trying to understand it
we're in murky waters so that's the
reason why we always
we're annoying with the subscribe or
share
or this because that's the only thing
that we got because all of this
even that all of this could be gone
tomorrow so at least that's my little
sum some for me
because all of these can be gone
tomorrow no lie yeah yeah
i'm operating on that on on that very
basis i don't i don't trust the platform
so i'm not even touching the money i
make from this i just throw it in my
bank account and leave it because i
i'm expecting rainy days personally um
but yeah what you're seeing this is just
with a private youtube channel that we
run
that we do for you guys and that like is
our source of income when you're talking
about your elected officials not being
able
to communicate with you guys we're
getting to a whole new level of problems
so i don't like it i i think it's it's a
very bad precedent and i hope you guys
understand why we're saying
there's not an endorsement of trump
there's not that he's just i'm
for people's ability to speak and i
don't think that means that all speech
is protected because we always have
limitations
but i do think in this case this is
really weird and you should be very
worried about the fact that they're all
colluding together
to make these bans happen the idea that
you can get banned from every platform
for saying something on one platform
is is nuts to me it's like i didn't even
violate your terms of service and you
still banned me
because of who i am is that what we're
doing now that's what we're doing now
based on
what political leadings i have who i
endorse that's what we're doing
it's crazy man so you know i'm just not
a fan and the idea that like
they ban some people on the platform
from doing some things but not others
it's just crazy like
what do you guys think yo
[Music]
foreign